hey everyone it's Jonah here again if
you're one of those people who are
blessed with bulky calves just like me
then today's workout is for you I can
understand how frustrating it can be
when you try to put a certain dress on
and it's just emphasizing on your calves
and all we're trying to do is to hide it
today's workout our five best slimming
calves moves to turn up your calves and
to slim it down so let's start so let's
start by doing sumo squats as a warm-up
20200 squats 10 feet wide apart to is
facing out and just squat down and up
this won't warm up our legs and our cast
at the same time to turn down house and
to sling your calves what we want to do
is low weight high wraps so therefore
use no weights at all except our body
weights or very light weights
okay so just 10 more times to warm up
our mix and our house and the first
workout will be my favorite workout soon
we'll squat with calf raises and I'm
just like - I have Balki cows I still
have bulky cows because its genetic but
I've managed to tone it down
it used to be horse when I was a teenage
alright last two one two good first like
a sumo squat car phrases so Sten tiptoe
okay all the way through and what we
want to do is to squat down tiptoe and
squat up and squeeze your cars and use
your cars to bring back up okay if you
find this typical 20 reps what you can
do is to bring your entire feet down as
you come up
tiptoe alright so let's do 20 times
tiptoe good choose which variation you
want to use there your really squeeze
your calves on the way up good job
five very good six seven eight nine
really keep your balance by looking
straight ahead ten half with that go
when I was a teenager a friend used to
joke around and say that everything I
eat goes straight to my car
that's how big it was don't get me wrong
it's still bulky because its genetic but
by doing this workout it has helped to
tone it down and slim it down keep going
last three one reads physicals two three
do it jump second workout is called
skater hops so imagine you're skating
and what you want to do is to hop from
left to right hop using your cuff and
push it back same thing we are going for
higher ups and no it's at all fifteen on
each side which will be 30 in total
okay ready choose your side and measure
you're helping stabilize yourself with
your cuffs cops go one get okay really
push with the cops three user comes to
push you to the other side or good job
by your knees five to reduce the impact
my hair is getting messy seven all right
really bad your knees up we shoot a
house eight nine
ten keep your balance look straight
ahead
one doing good two three four five one
more great great great job we're not
stopping yet third workout very commonly
done very effective calf raises so if
you have a high platform at home use
your platform if you're in the gym step
onto a high platform or even a stairs
what we want to do is to bring our chest
shoulder width apart facing front and
just keep our balance and just bring
your cows stand on tiptoe and bring it
down okay same thing we are doing 30
repetitions three different variations
so bring your heel as low as you can and
when you're up squeeze your calf
all right good let's go as you find more
of this good really stand if you're
standing on the platform you will feel
more it will add the intensity and I
encourage you to stand on a platform
good last two really squeeze your cuffs
on the way up and now stand with your
toes facing in alright what we want to
work on now is our inner cops so let's
get standing up keep your balance two
three four good job five it might feel
awkward but you look at these two it
seven eight nine
ten steel oncome raises they'll stand
out to work on the outer part okay go up
two three four all the way down five
without touching the floor six seven you
should really feel your counts working
and the muscles really burning up nine
ten good good good
and another move to slim down your count
is to stretch your calves stretching
your calves will elongate the muscles
that's what you would appear to the
consumer so just choose any wall that
you have I'm just going to use my wall
here support your body weight on to the
wall one foot forward in a 90 degrees
position one foot back straight and just
push the back leg down by pushing the
heels into the ground by doing this what
you should be feeling is your customers
are being stretched out on my right leg
okay and don't do it quick do it for at
least 30 seconds two times so just
holding really feel your car stretching
out if you don't feel it push your body
weight more into the wall I can hold it
up for 30 seconds at least just really
for your car stretching it up and allow
the muscles to stretch good now same
things on your side step forward bring
your left leg back and push your heels
into the ground and push your body
weight towards the wall good job I
remember holding for at least 30 seconds
and do it again
or you can hold it for one minute
one set good job and just release and
don't forget to stretch it on again the
fifth workout is to do long endurance
cardio so pick a card that you like
either running swimming they are really
good for your calves so do it for 30 to
40 minutes at a moderate pace two to
three times a week that will help to
burn fat and strip down on your cast as
well so let's do the entire set again
for the second time are you ready let's
start by squat with conferences tiptoe
let's go 20 times 1 really squeeze it
cause it's all not working on our calves
for this workout 3 good job 4
it will take time to simmer your cause
but you will see and notice the
difference
5 try to do this entire workout 2 to 3
times with me thanks good don't 6 8 9 10
halfway there 10 more keep going
tiptoe remember to look straight ahead
to keep your balance good job four five
come on five more
keep going six seven and next workout
skip the hops last two one two let's go
if you thing on your side one push you
the cops good three good job
five remember to bring your right leg
back good
seven I'll be there remember to bend
your knees to reduce the impact nine
let's go five more one two small three
four five and done next workout use the
platform if you can okay calf raises
let's go toes facing front Taniguchi if
you're not feeling this you can always
grab one two some light dumbbells all
right there are two is facing in keep
going ten more
I'm not feeling too well today but let's
push it through keep going
you should feel some sweat coming on
some really long sweat that is good keep
going
last three and now facing out okay ten
more and after this
don't forget your stretching stretching
really helps to elongate your muscles
not just where calves I would encourage
you to stretch your entire body out keep
going last five
get now onto the wall remember 30
seconds twice bring your right leg back
push your right leg heels into the floor
and lean your body weight against the
wall and just stretch it up if you're
not feeling it take a step on the back
okay 30 seconds twice all one minute for
one set hold it there this should be
really good for your calves and now
let's change the other side stop over
really push your heels in another great
position is also the down with stock or
the yoga pose that is really good to
stretch it elongate your calves as well
push it in just relax breathe in breathe
out
and just shake it out don't forget to do
your cardio workout as well at a
moderate intensity for 30 to 40 minutes
either jogging swimming or even dancing
they are really good cardio workout to
work in a cast and to elongate your calf
muscle I hope you like this for I gotta
do it at least twice a week and view it
in as part of your regular workout and
just start loving your calves like what
I have done at least they are strong and
not a week for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys